why did tuition rates get so high in the
United States let's preface this with I
to himself interested and I am a
professor so high tuition is that a bad
thing not for me okay so what we want to
understand is that the United States
higher education system is it's not
unique but it's unusual in that public
institutions of higher education have to
compete with private institutions of
higher education and what they compete
on is the quality of the education and
the quality of the student body now the
quality of the student body turns out to
be an important element for students
because who they get to be friends with
who they network with at the college and
university level has important bearing
on their opportunities in the rest of
their lives so tuition is a a mechanism
for sorting out how how strongly people
demand a particular level of education
it's also quite misleading the
university's price discriminate that is
they state a very high tuition level
which almost nobody pays so when people
debate tuition they need to look at the
actual tuition paid and not the rate
stated the actual tuition paid for
something like 70 or 75 percent of
undergraduate students is much lower
because they are given low-interest
loans or they are given scholarships or
other mechanisms that greatly reduce the
true tuition and that's the level of
tuition that public institutions compete
with I went to public institutions for
my entire education I went to Queens
College of the City University of New
York back in the 1960s when it was free
I came from an upper middle-class family
that could have afforded to pay some
tuition so the actual consequence of my
free tuition or today the relatively low
tuition
is that poor people in New York City
whose children were not going to
university but who were paying taxes to
the city of New York were subsidizing my
education probably a higher tuition rate
and then price discrimination such as we
see commonly and private universities is
a better system then I would not have
been subsidized bipolar people